SALLY: Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Wir sind gerade in der Türkei,
und zwar in der berühmten Rosenregion Isparta.
Isparta'ya hoş geldiniz. (Herzlich willkommen in Isparta.)
SAMIRA: Hoş bulduk. (Danke als Antwort auf "Willkommen".)
[Musik]
SALLY: Hier verbringen wir jetzt einige Tage,
denn wir wollen hier Rosen ernten
und daraus Rosenöl und Rosenwasser herstellen.
In Isparta wachsen wirklich unglaublich viele Rosen.
Daraus werden auch ganz oft Rosenöl und Rosenwasser hergestellt
und diese auch wirklich in die ganze Welt verschifft.
Wir sind jetzt hier,
weil wir unser eigenes Rosenwasser und Rosenöl herstellen wollen.
Wie und warum, zeige ich euch später.
Jetzt muss ich mich aber richtig beeilen,
denn die Rosen müssen jetzt noch vor der Mittagszeit geerntet werden.
Es hat was mit der Qualität zu tun.
Deswegen würde ich jetzt sagen,
gehe ich direkt nach hinten aufs Feld zu Murat, Ela und Samira
und helfe ihnen dabei
und erzähle euch gleich noch was zu den Rosen, okay?
Also kommt mal mit!
[Musik]
Die Isparta-Rose ist eine der hochwertigsten Rosen, die es gibt,
denn sie beinhaltet wirklich ganz viel teures
und sehr hochwertiges Rosenöl.
Die Rosen müssen aber noch vor 10 Uhr morgens geerntet werden.
D.h., man fängt hier wirklich schon um 5 Uhr an.
Die Rose hat nämlich nachts den höchsten Rosenölanteil,
um sich eben vor der nächtlichen Kälte zu schützen.
Je später es wird und je wärmer es am Tag wird,
umso weniger Rosenöl hat sie.
Also muss man bis 10 Uhr alles abgeerntet haben,
damit man einfach die höchste Qualität hat.
Deswegen steht man hier eben so ganz früh schon auf dem Feld
- hat aber auch den Vorteil, dass man sich keinen Sonnenbrand holt.
[Musik]
Die Rosenernte in Isparta erstreckt sich von
Ende April bis etwa Mitte/Ende Juni.
Geografisch gesehen liegt Isparta genau richtig.
Die roten Felder sind ummantelt von Wäldern des Taurusgebirges,
sodass die Täler gerade so viel Sonne abbekommen,
wie die Rosen benötigen.
Während es in anderen Regionen in der Türkei dann schon sehr heiß ist,
ist es früh morgens auf den Rosenfeldern noch sehr kühl,
weshalb die Rose dann auch das teure, hochwertige Rosenöl produziert,
um sich eben vor der nächtlichen Kälte zu schützen.
Dadurch, dass die Rosen hier nicht gespritzt sind
und alles wirklich rein biologisch ist,
kann man daraus auch Lebensmittel herstellen
- wie Rosenöl, was man verzehren kann, oder auch Rosenmarmelade.
Die kochen wir später auch noch im Dorf.
Also schade ist eigentlich, dass ihr es nicht riechen können,
weil es hier echt extrem gut riecht.
MURAT: Und wenn sie pflückt,
dann sind die Hände so klebrig vom Rosenöl, gell? [Sally stimmt zu]
Das ist Wahnsinn!
[Musik]
ELA: Ich habe dir schon einen Beutel gegeben.
Das ist jetzt schon mein 2. Beutel.
SALLY: Super! Du bist eine richtige Erntehelferin.
Die Isparta-Rose war übrigens auch die Heilpflanze des Jahres 2013.
Sie wird nämlich auch in der Aromatherapie eingesetzt,
wirkt praktisch entzündungshemmend, krampflösend und fiebersenkend
und wird zur seelischen und körperlichen Entspannung genutzt.
Das ist gerade praktisch so wie Paartherapie, gell Murat?
Bist du schon entspannt?
Oh, er ist wirklich romantisch. Oh mein Gott!
MURAT: Es ist DIE Rose!
Ich habe keine Rose gesehen, die so gut gerochen hat.
Wahnsinn, oder? [Sally stimmt zu]
[Musik]
SALLY: Jetzt sind wir gerade perfekt zur Mittagszeit da.
Die Damen hier im Dorf bereiten jetzt schon das Mittagessen vor.
Ich muss sagen, für uns ist es das Frühstück,
denn wir waren heute Morgen schon sehr früh auf.
D.h., wir machen jetzt eine ganz kurze Pause
und dann kommen die Rosen direkt zum Destillieren ins Haus.
[Musik]
500 kg Rosen werden mit 1.500 l reinem Wasser
des Taurusgebirges destilliert,
woraus letztendlich 400 l reines Rosenwasser gewonnen werden.
Jetzt haben wir hier diesen Kupferkessel.
Warum Kupfer?
Ihr kennt das ja auch aus meiner Küche.
Ich benutze auch ganz gerne meine Kupfertöpfe,
weil Kupfer einfach eine ganz, ganz tolle Wärmeleitfähigkeit hat
und Rosenwasser oder Rosenöl,
das im Kupferfass gewonnen wird,
hat einfach ein ganz besonderes Aroma.
Man hat diesen tollen Geruch und auch eben den tollen Geschmack.
Das Ganze wird jetzt hier auch nicht randvoll gefüllt.
Das könnt ihr euch auch wie mit Gulasch in einem Topf vorstellen:
Randvoll gefüllt bedeutet auch immer,
es wird immer gleich zu Matschepampe.
Hier haben die Rosen jetzt einfach genug Platz,
um ihr Aroma freizugeben,
sodass sie schön schwimmen können,
ohne dass sie sofort zerdrückt werden.
Ich verschließe jetzt den Kupferkessel.
Dann warten wir 1,5 Stunden.
Die Destillation beginnt jetzt gleich
und in der Zeit werden wir gleich Rosenmarmelade herstellen.
MURAT: Jetzt!
SALLY: Schön fest, damit Aromen darin bleiben, wo sie hingehören.
Normalerweise ist Rosenwasser ein Nebenprodukt,
das bei der Rosenölgewinnung anfällt.
Bei uns jedoch ist das Rosenwasser das Hauptprodukt,
weil wir das hochwertige Rosenöl nach dem Destillationsprozess
wieder dem Rosenwasser zufügen,
sodass die Wirkung der Rosen darin erhalten bleibt.
Jetzt haben wir euch da drin die moderne Anlage gezeigt,
aber früher wurden natürlich auch Rosenwasser ganz klassisch
und traditionell hergestellt - und zwar hier.
Das ist praktisch eine Rosenwasseranlage,
wie sie früher gebraucht wurde.
D.h., alle Rosenblätter kommen jetzt ganz erntefrisch hier rein.
[Musik]
Während ich jetzt hier aufs Rosenwasser warte,
kann ich schon einmal meine Rosenmarmelade herstellen,
aber dafür muss ich noch einmal ganz frische Rosen sammeln.
[Musik]
Jetzt kochen wir die Marmelade mit Cemile Teyze
und sie erklärt mir jetzt,
welche Rosen wir pflücken, denn sie sollen wirklich sehr frisch sein.
[Musik]
Ich habe gerade gesagt: Sie sieht so jung aus
und ob das von den Rosen kommt.
Da sagt sie: Ich weiß nicht.
CEMILE TEYZE: (Wollen wir darüber gehen?) [Sally bejaht]
[Musik]
SALLY: Die Rosenblätter sind jetzt schön gewaschen,
Da kommt jetzt auf 3 kg Rosenblätter
etwa ein 1/2 Kilo Zucker und der Saft einer Zitrone dazu.
Meine Geheimzutat wäre jetzt noch Vanilleextrakt,
aber das habe ich leider nicht dabei.
Und dann wird das Ganze schön durchgeknetet.
Hier Ela!
ELA: Was ist das alles?
SALLY: Für dich!
SAMIRA: Marmelade.
SALLY: Marmelade.
Also nachdem ich diese Muskelarbeit hier erledigt habe,
lasse ich das Ganze ein bisschen ziehen,
damit sich das Aroma schön entfalten kann.
[Musik]
Also auf 10 l Wasser kommen jetzt 10 kg Zucker.
Ich habe ja nicht gesagt, dass wird eine Light-Version.
Es wird eine Marmelade und die muss haltbar gemacht werden.
[Musik]
Ich fühle mich gerade wie eine Hexe mit ihrem Kessel,
aber ich bin keine Hexe.
Ich bin eine Kitchen Aid.
(Ja bitte?)
HELFERIN: (Jetzt setzen wir den Kessel auf das Feuer.)
SALLY: (Alles klar. Machen wir das zusammen? 1, 2, 3!)
Das muss ich jetzt eine halbe Stunde rühren,
bis das Ganze ein Zuckersirup wird, der auch schön dickflüssig ist
und dann kommen erst die Rosen dazu.
[Musik]
Rudern! Rudern, Murat!
Jetzt ist der Sirup eingekocht.
HELFERIN: (Das Sirup ist gekocht. Jetzt fügen wir sie hinzu).
[Musik]
SALLY: So darf es jetzt noch einmal eine halbe Stunde kochen
und wird dann in Gläser abgefüllt.
Also man muss schon sagen,
die türkische Rosenmarmelade ist sehr, sehr zuckerhaltig,
aber ich denke, das ist einfach auch die Tradition von früher,
denn man hat ja früher auch nicht so viele Kühlschränke gehabt
und musste praktisch die Marmelade mit viel Zucker haltbar machen.
Ich glaube, da gab es noch kein Umdenken.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile könnte man es auch mit weniger Zucker machen
und stattdessen ein bisschen was anderes dazugeben.
Josh, hörst du das?
Unser Rosenwasser!
Jetzt ist die Marmelade fertig und wird in Gläser abgefüllt.
Jetzt dürft euch nicht wundern:
Die türkische Marmelade ist immer so eine etwas flüssigere Marmelade
und ein bisschen zuckriger, aber trotzdem lecker.
Schmeckt gut, sehr gut! Sehr aromatisch!
[Musik]
Wir sind jetzt hier gerade in Güneykent.
Das ist eine Stunde vom Isparta-Zentrum weg.
Und zwar sind wir an einem richtig schönen Ort.
Neben uns sitzt Selim Bey.
Er ist Musiklehrer und er wird gleich was ganz Tolles vorspielen.
[Flötenmelodie]
Güneykent kennt ist der Wallfahrtsort von Yunus Emre.
Er war ein Dichter und Denker im 13. Jahrhundert
und prägte den anatolischen Humanismus
mit seinen zahlreichen Gedichten und Liedern.
Yunus Emre kommt aus der Tradition des Sufismus.
Er war stets auf der Suche nach Gerechtigkeit
und bemühte sich, ein vorbildlicher Diener Gottes zu sein.
Seine Botschaften haben auch wirklich die Welt erreicht.
Für ihn waren alle Menschen wert, geliebt zu werden,
unabhängig von seiner Sprache, Herkunft oder Religion.
In seiner Welt gab es keinen Platz für Hass, Streit und Wut.
Er sagte, man müsse Menschen erziehen, niemandem das Herz zu brechen,
die Lebewesen achten und Bescheidenheit zu einem Charakterzug machen.
Da es damals den Buchdruck noch nicht gab,
hat Yunus Emre seine Lebensweisheiten
durch Lieder und Gedichte an die Menschheit weitergegeben.
[Flötenmelodie]
Fake!
[Musik]
Jetzt machen wir etwas ganz Traditionelles,
was wir heute Morgen gefrühstückt haben: Lokur.
Das ist jetzt die Füllung.
Das Ganze ist ein Hefeteig, der salzig ist, haben sie gesagt.
Ich probiere ihn aber gleich mal,
damit ich das Rezept für euch zu Hause nachmachen kann.
Da ist Tahin drin, Pekmez, also Traubenmelasse,
Walnüsse und Haşaş, also Mohn.
[Musik]
So, jetzt machen wir hier gerade Gözleme.
Den Yufka haben wir jetzt ausgewellt.
Das wird jetzt hier einmal umgefaltet,
dass die 2 Seiten einfach rechteckig sind.
Dann kommt eine Käse-Kräutermischung rein.
Sie denken übrigens, ich mache das zum 1. Mal.
deswegen erklären sie mir alles.
[Musik]
TEYZE: (Mein süßes Kind!)
SALLY: (Hallo!)
METIN: (Hallo! Herzlich willkommen!)
SALLY: Vielen Dank!
METIN: (Schön, dass Sie da sind. Vielen Dank für Ihren Beitrag zu unserer Stadt.)
[Musik]
(Hier sehen wir Ismail Efendi.)
(Er hat die erste Rose aus Bulgarien mitgebracht.)
SALLY: Das ist Ismail Efendi.
Er hat damals die erste Rose aus Bulgarien gebracht.
Mein Opa, also der Papa von meiner Mama, war aus Bulgarien.
Er ist aus Bulgarien als Flüchtling praktisch in die Türkei gekommen,
hat sich dort in Erzincan angesiedelt.
Und dann sind sie von dort irgendwann nach Deutschland gekommen.
Also habe ich auch so ein bisschen eine Verbundenheit nach Bulgarien.
Die Erntefrau und ihre Familie.
Ich glaube, dass sie wahrscheinlich so
im 18. Jahrhundert oder noch früher gelebt hat.
Wenn ich mir die Kleidung
dieser beiden Herrschaften und Frauschaften anschaue,
dann wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen aus der Moderne.
Aber der links könnte aus dem Mittelalter stammen.
(Ach du bist es! Ich dachte, es ist ein Baby. Ela!)
[Musik]
METIN: (Ich bedanke mich für eure touristische Unterstützung in Güneykent.)
SALLY: (Vielen Dank!)
Ich habe eine Auszeichnung bekommen, weil er sagt,
dass ich euch diesen kleinen Ort Güneykent gezeigt habe.
Und er lädt alle ganz herzlich dazu ein, hier einmal herzukommen,
das Museum anzuschauen, einen Kaffee zu trinken.
Also kommt gerne einmal vorbei.
Ein richtig süßes, kleines Dorf.
(Danke sehr!)
(Herzlich willkommen in Isparta!)
SAMIRA: (Danke!)
SALLY: Wir gehen jetzt gleich ins Viertel.
Hier seht ihr Gülcü Ismail Efendi.
Das ist der Roselhändler Ismail Efendi.
Ismail Efendi kam praktisch aus Bulgarien in die Türkei
und hat damals die Rosenpflanze illegal mit sich mitgeschleppt.
So hat es praktisch angefangen,
dass Isparta die Rosenregion wurde.
und dass man hier eben damit Geld verdiente.
[Musik]
Wir haben jetzt einen Ausflug nach Sagalassos gemacht.
Wir sind hier in der türkischen Provinz Burdur,
immer noch in Isparta.
Die Berge, die wir hier sehen, sind die Berge,
die wir im Rosental gesehen haben,
also hier aus dem Hintergrund.
[Musik]
Ja?
ELA: Da ist ein Flügelhund!
SALLY: Ein Flügelhund?
Wow! Ist der aus der antiken Zeit? [Ela bejaht]
Ja, oder?
[Musik]
Wo sind sie, die schönen Rosen Felder?
Da!
[Musik]
Also zurück zum Rosenwasser,
welches mittlerweile destilliert und abgekühlt ist.
Wir haben unser Rosenwasser in
2 unterschiedlichen, unabhängigen Laboren testen lassen.
Hier sind wir jetzt gerade in unserer Abfüllanlage,
wo wir auch intern zusätzlich eigene Labore haben
und stets die Qualität kontrollieren.
Jetzt haben wir ein ausgezeichnetes Rosenwasser
und ich finde es ganz wichtig, dass das Rosenwasser auch ausgezeichnet verpackt wird.
Ihr habt ja auch gesehen,
bei der Rosenernte haben wir auf Plastik verzichtet.
Die Rosen werden schön in Jutebeuteln verpackt,
werden dann eben ins Destillat gebracht
und von dort aus direkt in den Kupferkesseln aufbewahrt.
Mir ist wichtig, dass kein Mikroplastik in das Rosenwasser gelangt.
Das heißt, ich möchte auf Kunststoff verzichten.
Da hat man nämlich ganz oft das Problem,
dass auch z.B. bei Kleidung
Mikroplastik durch das Waschen in der Umwelt landet
MURAT: oder Mikroplastik durch PET-Flaschen in Getränken landet.
SALLY: Da möchten wir darauf verzichten
und haben uns deswegen für Glasflaschen entschieden.
Es gibt natürlich Hersteller, die Kunststoffflaschen nehmen.
Und zwar wird ganz viel aus Isparta z.B. nach China exportiert,
weil der Rosenmarkt in China auch riesig ist.
Da ist es einfach schwieriger, Glas zu exportieren,
weil wenn da einmal eine Palette kaputt geht,
hat man wirklich ganz, ganz viel Verlust.
Deswegen hat man dann eben Kunststoffflaschen.
Für uns kommt es nicht in Frage.
Türkei und Deutschland sind ja nicht so weit entfernt
und das klappt mit dem Transport auch ganz gut.
Daher die Glasflaschen.
Alles ganz natürlich.
Worauf ich noch geachtet habe:
Ich benutze mein Rosenwasser
für die Haare, für die Haut, fürs Gesicht
und vor allem als Gesichtstonic.
D.h., ich reinige mein Gesicht und sprüh es mir danach auf.
Deswegen kam für mich so eine Verpackung nicht in Frage,
wo man es einfach ausschüttet,
denn ich möchte, dass das Rosenwasser direkt in meinem Gesicht landet
und nicht erst auf einem Wattepad oder in den Händen.
Daher haben wir jetzt hier einen Sprühkopf,
haben uns für diese schöne Flasche entschieden,
so ein bisschen verdunkelt
und auch einen Metallsprühkopf verwendet.
Das einzige Kunststoffteil, das wir haben,
und es ging einfach nicht anders,
ist dieser Schlauch hier am Dispenser dran,
und das geht einfach nicht, weil man es raussprühen muss.
So haben wir jetzt eine schöne natürliche Verpackung
und für den Versand alles schön hier in der Kartonage,
damit die Flasche hier dann reinkommen kann
und einfach beim Transport nichts kaputtgeht.
Und vor allem finde ich,
ist es eine richtig schöne, hübsche Geschenkidee.
Schaut mal!
Jetzt haben wir die Glasflaschen gesehen.
Ich würde sagen, wir gehen direkt ans Abfüllen.
[Musik]
Jetzt gehen wir mal gemeinsam in den Saliha-Abfüllraum.
Nicht ich werde abgefüllt, sondern das Rosenwasser natürlich.
MITARBEITER: Hallo Frau Özcan, herzlich willkommen zu unserem Abfüllraum.
[Musik]
SALLY: Also hier wird jetzt das Rosenwasser abgefüllt.
Es ist so, dass es einfach mit Sauerstoff
auch gar nicht erst in Berührung kommt.
Es kommt nämlich direkt aus den Tanks
in die sterilisierte und desinfizierte Anlage,
läuft hier durch und wird praktisch auch maschinell verschlossen.
Und dann können da vorne meine 2 fleißigen Helfer, Murat und Samira,
die Glasflaschen in die Kartons verpacken und dann sind wir fertig.
Also die erste Ladung Rosenwasser haben wir hergestellt
und ich starte die Maschine.
Los geht's!
[Musik]
Ihr seht schon, so ganz ohne Handarbeit geht es nicht.
- ist dann doch ein sehr kleiner Familienbetrieb,
aber das ist ja auch schön.
Dann sind hier wieder nette Menschen mit dabei,
die mit uns gemeinsam wundervolle Dinge zu tun.
MURAT: Samira, du musst schneller machen.
SALLY: Ich schwör's dir! Mach schneller, sonst sind wir erledigt.
[Musik]
Familienbetrieb Özcan, ich helf euch noch.
Verpacken und dann nehmen wir alles mit nach Waghäusel.
Okay, wir nehmen vielleicht nur 1 Karton mit.
Den Rest lassen wir dann zukommen.
[Musik]
Also da ist es nun, mein eigenes Rosenwasser.
Wir haben wirklich lange überlegt, wie wir es nennen wollen
und hatten ganz viele Termine,
haben gemeinsam gebrainstormt und irgendwie …
Ich meine, ich liebe meine Marke „Sally".
Ich steh da ja auch dafür und ich bin ja auch Sally
- voll und ganz, schon seit der 5. Klasse, falls ihr euch erinnert.
Aber irgendwie dachte ich, passt diese pinkfarbene Blume,
die ich über alles liebe,
doch nicht so sehr zu meinem Rosenwasser.
Dann kamen wir wirklich zum Entschluss,
diesem Rosenwasser meinen natürlichen Namen zu geben, nämlich Saliha.
Der Name, den wir meine Eltern vor einigen Jahren gegeben haben
- am 24. August.
Der Name hat auch echt eine schöne Bedeutung.
Er heißt die Fromme, die Anständige, die Hilfsbereite, die Ehrliche.
Im Prinzip wurde mir der Name „Sally" eigentlich auch nur gegeben,
weil es einfach so ein Spitzname ist und Abkürzung von Sally
- und vielleicht auch, weil Murat meinen Namen nicht aussprechen kann.
Das hat ihm natürlich auch ein bisschen geholfen, mich zu benennen,
weil er immer „Salliha“ statt „Saliha“ Sally: sagt.
Ich finde, es ein schöner Name
und steht auch so ein bisschen für Natürlichkeit.
Ich wollte einfach mit diesem Rosenwasser etwas Neues beginnen
und einfach dieser neu kreierten Marke einen neuen Namen geben.
Daher der Name.
Wir sind jetzt gerade im August.
Im Mai wurden die Rosenblätter gepflückt,
es wurde destilliert und abgefüllt.
Jetzt im Moment hat es den Weg zu uns nach Deutschland gefunden,
auch zu uns im Online-Shop.
Ich verwende dieses Rosenwasser zum Kochen und Backen,
aber auch als Kosmetikprodukt.
Ihr könnt damit z.B. Gebäck verfeinern.
Wenn ihr Muffins zubereitet, könnt ihr es damit besprühen.
Ihr könnt es in Sirup einarbeiten und Baklava herstellen.
Also alles, was ihr praktisch mit Rosenwasser zubereiten würdet,
könnt ihr damit machen,
weil es einfach ein sehr natürliches Produkt ist
und wirklich nichts drin ist außer 100 % Rosenwasser.
Bei der Kosmetik verwende ich so:
Ich verwende es morgens und abends im Gesicht
Ich nehme es vor allem morgens:
Da bin ich ja noch nicht geschminkt.
Da wache ich auf gehe ins Bad
und reinige mein Gesicht mit einem Reinigungsgel,
trockne es dann ab
und anschließend sprühe ich das Rosenwasser ins Gesicht,
wische es dann mit einem Wattepad ab
und dann kommt meine tägliche Pflegecreme drauf.
Am Abend benutze ich es auch als Gesichtstonicum
und verwende zuerst ein Reinigungsgel, um Make-up zu entfernen,
und sprühe dann das Rosenwasser wieder ins Gesicht.
Rosenwasser hat auch den Vorteil, dass es aszendierend ist.
D.h., es verschließt dann auch wieder alle Poren
und ihr bekommt einfach einen krassen Frischeeffekt im Gesicht.
Dieser Duft der Rose ist kurz da,
verfliegt dann aber auch wieder, was auch ganz gut ist,
weil man ja nicht den ganzen Tag nach Rose riechen möchte.
Danach verwende ich auch meine Tages- oder Nachtcreme.
Für die Haare mache ich es dann so,
dass ich nach der Haarwäsche oder auch mal morgens,
wenn ich auch den Kindern die Haare kämme,
sprühe ich es einfach in die Längen und Spitzen,
teilweise auch auf die Kopfhaut, falls er immer trockene Kopfhaut habt.
Es ist für Haut und Haare wirklich ein Allround-Produkt,
das Feuchtigkeit spendet, auch Juckreiz mildert
und einfach die Haut und die Haare mit Nährstoffen versorgt.
Ich hab euch ja auch bei der Produktion gezeigt,
wie das Rosenwasser hergestellt wird.
Es bleibt ja etwas übrig, nämlich die ausgedrückten Rosenblätter.
Entweder kann man sie als Dünger verwenden
oder man kann sie auch weiterverarbeiten.
Wir haben dahingehend gebrainstormt
und uns einfach schlau darüber gemacht.
Ihr wisst ja,
wir haben letztes Jahr auch unser eigenes Olivenöl hergestellt
und auch da bleibt sozusagen der Presskuchen.
Also die Oliven Reste bleiben ja übrig.
Wir haben damals schon ein bisschen mitgedacht und haben uns gefragt:
Was könnte man denn aus den Olivenresten machen?
Aus diesen ausgedrückten Oliven,
die den kompletten Geschmack sozusagen an das Öl abgegeben haben
und haben damals schon eine Naturseife hergestellt.
Diese haben wir jetzt mit den Rosenblättern verfeinert
und einfach eine Olivenöl-Rosenseife hergestellt,
womit man sich schön die Hände waschen kann.
Ich finde es einfach immer schön, wenn man Dinge ganzheitlich betrachtet.
Es ist ja genauso wie mit allem,
dass man einfach gerade Pflanzen und Tiere,
wenn man sie wirklich im Nutzen hat,
dass man sie einfach komplett verwendet und verbraucht,
sodass gar kein Müll entsteht und alles,
auch die ganzen Nährstoffe und wertvollen Inhaltsstoffe,
komplett verwendet werden.
Deswegen haben wir sozusagen hier
das Rosenöl und das Rosenwasser in unserem Olivenöl drin
Das reine Olivenöl aus der Frühernte und alles, was übrig war,
haben wir verpackt und eine schöne Rosenseife daraus hergestellt.
Die wollen wir euch jetzt in der Anfangszeit
einfach so zum Rosenwasser als Geschenk dazugeben,
weil ich finde, dass es einfach eine schöne Idee ist
und vielleicht gefällt sie euch ja genauso gut.
Mal schauen, was alles daraus wird.
Also heute wollte ich euch einfach einmal zeigen,
dass wir eine neue Marke erschaffen haben, ein neues kleines Baby
und ich bin ganz glücklich, dass ich es heute mit euch teilen durfte.
Vielen Dank fürs Einschalten.
Vielen Dank für den wunderschönen Film, Josh.
Ich habe ihn ja im Vorfeld schon gesehen.
Danke, dass ihr jetzt auch bei der Premiere live mit dabei seid.
Ich bin echt schon gespannt auf euer Feedback und auf eure Kommentare,
was ihr zu unserem neuen Baby sagt.
Bis zum nächsten Mal und bis zur nächsten Woche.
Tschüss!
Am Sonntag gibt es vielleicht noch ein Rezept damit.
Bleibt gespannt!
Wir haben auch …
Ich finde die Verpackung so schön.
Also da haben sich echt alle bei uns im Team
einfach so viele Gedanken gemacht.
Ach schön!
Ich liebe es einfach, das Rosenwasser.
Es riecht so schön und so natürlich.
Ich glaube, die Ela macht sich jetzt aus der Verpackung
so ein Kaleidoskop oder ein Fernrohr.
Also, einen schönen Abend! Tschüss!
[Musik]
ELA: Ein Löwe mit Flügeln - gibt's das überhaupt?
Die Flügel sehen aus wie eine Tulpe.
AUS DEM HINTERGRUND: War das dein Witz?
SARAH: War's schon? [Ela bejaht]
[Alle lachen]
ELA: Noch einer?
Eine Tankstelle sagt zu einem Tuch:
Hey Tuch, ich will auch ein Tuch sein.
[Ela sagt etwas, das Murat nicht versteht.]
MURAT: Was sagt sie?
SALLY: Sie sagt: Ich steche mir auch den Fingern sage gar kein Aua.
Also sagt sie einfach: Heul leise!
MURAT: Ach so!
JOSH: Komm, Murat! Wir machen noch so eine Aufnahme,
wie du eine Rose pflückst und sie in den Mund nimmst.
[Alle lachen]
SALLY: Ich glaube, er dachte, wie so ein Tangotänzer.
MURAT: Ihr seid ja bescheuert!
SALLY: Macht nix, die ist nicht gespritzt, ist vielleicht nur ein bisschen …
MURAT: Die kann man aber … Schmeckt ein bisschen komisch nach …
JOSH: Okay, weißt du, was? Klemm sie dir einfach hinters Ohr!
SALLY: So richtig romantisch, Murat.
Er kann es halt nicht. Er kann nicht romantisch sein.
MURAT: Ich kann es nicht.
Ich hab da … Ich bin da …
SALLY: … Romantik-Legastheniker.
Zeig!
Aww, darf ich deine Rosenkönigin sein? [Murat verneint]
Deine Gülşah? (Türkisch für Rosenkönigin)
MURAT: Nein, ich will nicht deine Gülşah sein.
Du kannst auch nicht meine Gülşah sein.
Ich bin ein Krieger.
SALLY: Aber ich kann dir auch Güllaç kochen.
MURAT: Ja, ich habe hier kein Internet.
Ist jetzt nicht schlimm.
Eigentlich ist das schon schlimm.
Das Problem ist, dass ich euch gern zeigen würde, was hier alles ist,
aber ich kann keine Storys machen.
Ja, so habe ich es nur für mich und das ist immer das Problem
- die schönen Seiten des Lebens.
Ich würde es gerne mit euch teilen, aber es geht nicht.
Ich würde auch gerne hier wohnen.
Ihr habt kein Geruchsfernsehen,
aber ich rieche momentan z.B. das Frühstück,
ich rieche die Rosen.
Die machen ja auch Gözleme.
D.h., ich rieche das angebrannte Holz.
Es ist wunderschön!
Dann hörst du die Vögel zwitschern.
Dann hast du hier einen Esel, ein Hund liegt da.
Der Hund liegt einfach nur darum.
Hast du den Hund da hinten gesehen?
Guck mal hier!
(Komm mal her! Komm mal her!)
Der kommt auch nicht, der Kleine. Er ist einfach weitergelaufen.
Das war ihm egal.
Aber ich hole mir jetzt ein Eis. Dann kommt er bestimmt gleich.
SALLY: Morgens früh um 6 kocht die kleine Hex.
Morgens früh um 7 schabt sie gelbe Rüben.
Morgens früh um 8 wird Kaffee gemacht.
Morgens früh um 9 geht sie in die Scheun'.
Feuert an um 11, kocht dann bis um 12.
Fröschebein und Krebs und Fisch,
hurtig Kinder, kommt zu Tisch!
ELA: Josh, mein Bein tut weh!
JOSH: Oh Gott!
Welches denn?
Bist du drauf gefallen?
Echt? Oh Gott!
Heute oder gestern?
ELA: Heute bin ich gefallen.
SALLY: Es war gerade so witzig.
Die Frau da vorne lief vorbei und sagte so:
Türkçe konuşuyor musunuz?
Heißt: Sprechen Sie Türkisch?
Ich: Ja.
Sagt sie: Seid ihr YouTuber oder so?
Ich: Jaaa?!
Sie: Da vorne ist ein Kebap, der ganz berühmt ist. Da müsst ihr hin!
Ich: Sehen wir so stark nach YouTubern aus? [Lacht]
Sehen wir aus wie Touris? [Josh bejaht]
Vielleicht ein bisschen, mit Fotografin …
SARAH: Zu mir! Gib mir mehr! [Beide lachen]
SALLY: Hör auf! Sie haben uns …
Wir sind nicht mehr getarnt.
Man!
SARAH: Mit Kamera …
SALLY: Ja okay … Kommt!